[Música]
estos rascacielos están a la altura de
las ambiciones desmedidas de Qatar pero
quienes construyeron las torres de doha
jamás tendrán los medios para vivir en
ellas
son trabajadores que viven lejos del
centro de la ciudad al final de estas
autopistas
para llegar un trabajador keniano nos
guía
aceptó dar su testimonio a condición de
permanecer anónimo
Afirma haberle pagado 1500 dólares a una
agencia de reclutamiento keniana por su
visa y su pasaje de avión
pero solo después de haber llegado al
país en 2020
supo Cuál era la empresa catari que lo
había contratado
[Música]
cuando llegué ese mismo día empecé a
trabajar
al principio hacíamos cemento para los
edificios
en fin un trabajo de construcción
durante el verano hace mucho calor aquí
la temperatura a veces supera los 50
grados no es fácil cuando trabajamos
afuera el calor nos golpea uno tiene la
sensación de que se va a morir
al igual que la mayoría de los
trabajadores extranjeros Ibrahim vive en
un alojamiento concedido por su
empleador a decenas de kilómetros del
centro de la ciudad
en estos complejos de edificios aislados
de todo
cada noche los buses de la empresa
recogen a los trabajadores en las obras
al no tener otro medio de transporte
estos hombres son prisioneros del
desierto
[Música]
si uno no tiene un auto cuando nos ven
caminando por aquí durante la noche y
los guardias de seguridad llaman a la
policía
piensan que nos vamos a fugar del
recinto
[Música]
cuando llegó Ibrahim grabó un video con
sus colegas En ese momento estaban
llenos de Esperanza su nuevo empleador
les prometía un salario entre dos y tres
veces más alto que en su país de origen
con alojamiento y comidas incluidas
la primera desilusión fue Ver el estado
de las instalaciones
así vivimos
está sucio huele mal
nuestra vida es un infierno
Nadie puede saber que estoy haciendo
esto
en Qatar publicar imágenes negativas del
país se sanciona con la expulsión los
periodistas tienen prohibido el acceso a
estos complejos pero desesperados por
sus condiciones de vida Ibrahim y sus
compañeros de habitación corrieron el
riesgo de dejarnos entrar con una cámara
Desde los primeros días estos obreros
han limpiado por su cuenta lo que han
podido pero todavía carecen de lo básico
[Música]
Esta es nuestra habitación
miren
siempre fácil explotar algo
por la noche Hay personas que duermen en
el suelo así
porque nos dejan aquí
la empresa dijo que nos daría camas
pero aquí no hay comedores o neveras ni
siquiera un lugar para cocinar
así preparamos la comida
simplemente Tratamos de sobrevivir
miren Esto es lo que compramos
no nos dan nada esto es todo lo que
comemos
ya no podemos más con esto que nos está
pasando estamos cansados
no tengo nada más que decir
aparte del alojamiento insalubre estos
trabajadores afirman no haber recibido
su salario en meses
todos los días dicen que nos van a dar
nuestro salario pero no nos dan nada
ha pasado casi un año y no soy solo yo
todos mis amigos también
Tratamos de hablar con el empleador pero
amenazó con Llamar a la policía algunos
quieren volver a su país
otros quieren cambiar de empresa
Pero el empleador confiscó nuestros
pasaportes que podemos hacer esto es
esclavitud es como una prisión
es una violación a los Derechos Humanos
no es justo no es justo vivir así
vamos hay que irse
igual que Ibrahim
más de dos millones y medio de
extranjeros viven y trabajan en Qatar
el millonario emirato trae esta mano de
obra desde Asia y África gracias al
dinero de los hidrocarburos
estos inmigrantes representan el 90% de
la población
[Música]
ellos han construido todas las
infraestructuras para el mundial de
fútbol el aeropuerto el metro los
hoteles de lujo y por supuesto los
estadios totalmente nuevos
tan solo en este 8000 obreros trabajaron
día y noche durante cuatro años
afuera Este muro pretende rendirles
homenaje
pero las fotografías generan dudas sobre
la cantidad de obreros sacrificados en
nombre de los delirios de grandeza por
su parte los cataríes ya están pensando
Más allá del Campeonato de fútbol el
país se postuló para ser el anfitrión de
los Juegos Olímpicos y sueña con
convertirse en una capital mundial de
eventos deportivos
[Música]
como árabe y katari siento un gran
orgullo de Dios que nos haya dado la
oportunidad de organizar el mundial de
fútbol
es un país ambicioso y quiere ser el
anfitrión de los mayores torneos
internacionales
gracias gracias a Dios Ahora tenemos la
infraestructura y los estadios para
ellos pienso rescatar está listo para
hacer la serie de cualquier evento
deportivo nuestra ambición no se
detendrá con el mundial de fútbol
para este primer mundial organizado en
medio oriente
Qatar espera atraer un millón y medio de
Seguidores y fanáticos del fútbol
cuatro semanas de diversión hechas
realidad gracias al arduo trabajo de
cientos de miles de trabajadores
[Música]
vinimos a este centro comercial en doha
con estas empleadas Filipinas
filmamos con el teléfono móvil para no
ser detenidos por los guardias de
seguridad
cada mes Rachel de camiseta negra le
envía casi todos su salario unos 400
dólares a sus cinco hijos
es importante para tu familia Sí ellos
están esperando mi salario
por los pasillos de mármol se cruzan dos
universos en la cima de la escala social
los hogares cataríes tienen un ingreso
promedio de 20 mil dólares al mes
para ellos el centro comercial es un
parque de atracciones donde nada es
demasiado caro
[Aplausos]
en el extremo opuesto Rachel y sus
amigas se conforman con mirar
A qué le estás tomando foto a la
decoración le estoy haciendo una foto
a quien se las vas a enviar a mis hijos
para mostrarles el interior del centro
comercial
Rachel llegó a Qatar en 2018
trabaja para un salón de belleza
administrado por una mujer catari
su jefa la manda a hacer manicuras
pedicuras y masajes a domicilio yo hice
estas uñas postizas
por lo general empezamos a las 9 de la
mañana
y trabajamos hasta las 8:30 de la noche
Pero bueno si un cliente quiere que la
cita sea a las 10 de la noche
Estas mujeres son alojadas por su jefa y
no tienen permiso para salir solas
dicen que en tres años nunca han tenido
vacaciones
incluso cuando su marido murió el año
pasado Rachel no pudo tomarse un solo
día de descanso
tienen días libres
días libres no no
Hoy es la primera vez que tenemos un día
libre entero la primera vez
en teoría tenemos derecho a un día de
pausa al mes pero solo nos dan unas
horas
dos o tres horas nomás sabían eso antes
de venir a acatar
sí lo sabíamos está en el contrato que
firmamos
pero a veces en Qatar no respetan la ley
sobre los días libres
pensábamos que vamos a tener un día de
descanso Cuando llegamos a cantar
y al final resultó que no
pero Hoy tuvimos suerte la jefa nos
libero tener Solo un día libre en tres
años es ilegal incluso encantar pero
Rachel y sus amigas esperan que su
sacrificios den frutos algún día
cuando llegan los inmigrantes que
provienen de todas partes del mundo
suelen ser pobres y sueñan con la
extensión social
sus ejemplos las personas que ya
lograron acceder a la clase media
profesores enfermeros o contadores
empleados en hoteles o restaurantes
administradores de tiendas y pequeñas
empresas
Sin ellos el país no podría funcionar
en el primer piso de este edificio esta
empresa de filtros de agua es dirigida
por una mujer de India
de 47 años está orgullosa de mostrarnos
lo que ha logrado Hola hola
vendemos fuentes de agua como estas
el filtro elimina la sal y el cloro del
agua porque aquí en doha el agua es
salada
se puede servir agua fría con esta llave
y para el té o el café sale agua
caliente de aquí
Hola a todos espero que nos vaya bien
este mes que sea tranquilo y alegre y
sobre todo que hagamos muchos negocios
el mes pasado todos trabajaron muy bien
estoy contenta está muy bien
empezó hace 22 años como vendedora
hoy dirige un equipo de 14 personas
todos vienen del subcontinente indio y
reciben un salario casi 10 veces más
alto que en su país pero deben ganarselo
cuál es tu objetivo para el mes 15.000
no es suficiente para ti para ti tampoco
15.000 no es suficiente
acabas de volver de vacaciones
entre 22 y 25
esto Me encanta es mi pan de cada día lo
es todo para mí mi casa mi oficina todo
está antoja por eso decidiste venir a
catarro claro
y gracias a Dios
Qatar me ha dado todo
cada mes farsana recibe una decena de
hojas de vida de nuevos candidatos a la
inmigración
para estos indios
Qatar representa una especie del Dorado
es un lugar emocionante donde hay muchas
oportunidades
[Música]
en India no hay oportunidades para ganar
dinero o adquirir experiencia por eso la
gente viene aquí Bueno
pueden irse a trabajar Muchas gracias
las personas en el extranjero se mueren
por venir aquí tienen la impresión de
que los lingotes de oro crecen en los
árboles que van a venir y que será fácil
pero no es tan simple el éxito cuesta
sudor y lágrimas
ser exitoso en doha tiene un precio
la ley obliga a estar bajo el patrocinio
de un catarín
este sistema que mantiene a los
extranjeros bajo tutela se llama cafala
si uno no es catarín como yo que vengo
de India y quiere montar una empresa
aquí hay que tener un socio local ese
socio posee el 51% de la empresa él es
el propietario y también se lleva al 51%
de las ganancias
Entonces cómo funciona el socio se lleva
algo cada mes
es decir se establece una suma de cuánto
le corresponde al mes
hay que aceptar estas condiciones sabe
hay que hacer concesiones y ceder para
poder avanzar en los negocios hay que
ser flexible
no puedo ser demasiado exigente porque a
fin de cuentas Este es su país
[Música]
dice que se lleva bien con su socio una
suerte para ella porque en caso de
conflicto la voz de los residentes
extranjeros tiene poco peso frente a la
de los cataríes
[Música]
nos encontramos con Ibrahim en un centro
comercial
después de casi un año sin salario la
empresa que lo explotaba lo transfirió
aquí
nos hicieron venir a este centro
comercial
para trabajar hasta 13 horas al día
[Música]
su nueva tarea llenar las bolsas de las
compras y desinfectar los carritos en
este supermercado una franquicia de la
marca francesa carrefour para los países
del Golfo
[Música]
la empresa subcontratista catari para la
que trabaja le presentó este empleo como
un ascenso porque le aseguraron que
obtendría propinas además de un salario
mensual de 400 dólares
el administrador nos dijo les van a dar
propinas es bueno para ustedes
van a acumular las propinas serán entre
15 y 30 dólares y con eso pueden comprar
comida
yo al principio quería rechazarlo no
quería hacer este tipo de trabajo porque
no se sabe si las personas van a dar
dinero o no los tres primeros meses no
recibimos ningún salario al cabo de tres
meses hicimos una huelga
Entonces el administrador dijo el
próximo que haga una huelga será
expulsado del país
fue para asustarnos
el chantaje funcionó y los huelguistas
retomaron el trabajo
cuatro meses después como seguían sin
recibir su pago Ibrahim y sus colegas
volvieron a protestar
en Qatar los sindicatos están prohibidos
y en nombre de la seguridad el régimen
reprime severamente todas las
manifestaciones
Por casualidad el Ministerio de trabajo
está justo enfrente del supermercado
decidimos ir al tribunal del Ministerio
del trabajo
Cuando llegamos les explicamos nuestra
situación y nos dijeron que iban a
ocuparse de nosotros pero que no querían
que siguiéramos en
huelgantes que si continuamos llamarían
a la policía
unos minutos después llegó la policía
los detuvieron
Nos llevaron a la estación y algunos Nos
soltaron
a mí me soltaron pero deportaron a mis
amigos pedimos permiso para poder
visitar los tribunales de los que habla
Ibrahim
catar los avión 2018 en respuesta a las
críticas internacionales sobre el trato
a los obreros a medida que se acercaba
el mundial de fútbol
entramos acompañados Por funcionarios
del Ministerio de información los de
blanco
esta empleada lleva los periodistas a
conocer la sala de audiencia totalmente
nueva
aquí se sienta el juez
los miembros de la corte y los
huelguistas es en este lugar donde la
justicia catari debería aplicar las
nuevas leyes sobre el salario mínimo o
el tiempo de trabajo
recibimos muchísimos casos hoy la sesión
empieza a las 2 de la tarde tenemos 25
casos
muchos están relacionados con empleados
de empresas de construcción
no llegan muchos muchos vamos a aumentar
la cantidad de tribunales pronto habrá
cinco es decir cinco jueces y se podrán
tratar más casos
por ahora la gran mayoría de los casos
están en espera por falta de personal
en diciembre pasado el Ministerio
reconoció haber recibido más de 2.000
quejas pero solo haber tratado 69
los empleados recibirán su dinero Aunque
lo tenga que pagar la empresa policía el
país o el fondo de solidaridad lo van a
recibir y la empresa será sancionada hay
sanciones
hay muchos
pero ya no tenemos tiempo va a llegar el
juez Entonces si quieren firmar el
tribunal aprovechen Eso es todo
imposible filmar la sala de espera o
hablar con los demandantes
dejen de filmar deben irse de esta área
Tenemos que irnos
deben irse de esta área
con estas reformas legislativas
Qatar ahora puede presumir de ser el
país más progresista de la Península
arábiga pero en su oficina el portavoz
del ministerio reconoce entre líneas que
los textos no siempre se aplican
al principio cuando empezamos las
reformas
por supuesto algunos jefes de empresas
se opusieron a estas leyes y me parece
que es normal
las personas tienen tendencia a estar en
contra del cambio o en contra de todo lo
que sea nuevo pero con el tiempo
avanzado
ahora Estamos en la fase de
implementación Y enfrentamos algunos
retos tenemos que sensibilizar a los
jefes de empresa y también a los
empleados
formar bien a los funcionarios de los
establecimientos públicos y de los
ministerios
en estas zonas en obra de doha los
principales interesados ya han visto
algunos progresos
[Música]
Nuestra Empresa ha hecho esfuerzos antes
nuestra situación era
peorbia
ahora todo el mundo en Qatar recibe al
menos 270 dólares al mes incluso estando
en el nivel más bajo se gana mínimo 270
dólares
Es verdad que ahora hay tribunales a los
que puedo huir
si mi empresa comete una atrocidad pero
no es tan sencillo no estoy en mi país
No voy a tratar de pelear porque ni
siquiera sabría A quién dirigirme
Honestamente
o de sri lanka está aquí para trabajar y
ganar dinero para mantener a su familia
y ayudar a su país si no lo consigue no
se va a agotar peleando aquí
en el peor de los casos renuncia a su
trabajo y se devuelve a su casa en
teoría las nuevas leyes permiten
sancionar a empresas como la de Ibrahim
pero en la práctica las ongs
internacionales denuncian una cultura de
la impunidad que se mantiene
nuestra situación está estancada
los tribunales nos repiten no se
preocupen nos encargaremos hablaremos
con su jefe Hasta que perdamos la
esperanza eso es lo que quieren
realmente necesitamos ayuda por qué no
nos ayudan por qué
al cabo de un año de espera Ibrahim pudo
recuperar su pasaporte y rescindir su
contrato de trabajo pero dice que nunca
recibió sus salarios atrasados
la empresa en cuestión es muy conocida
en Qatar ha sido denunciada varias veces
hasta por la prensa local
[Música]
la redacción de doha news un portal de
noticias en línea ha seguido varios de
los casos
[Música]
hazard Cómo vas con el reportaje estoy
en eso avance bastante ayer y hoy lo voy
a terminar
la empresa al jacira que no tiene nada
que ver con la cadena de televisión con
el mismo nombre posee varias filiales en
los sectores de Obras Públicas
restauración y automóviles
en este artículo la periodista investigó
sobre un grupo de guardias de seguridad
que tampoco habían recibido su pago
no es la primera vez que esta empresa
infringe la ley
ya habíamos cubierto el tema
este es solo un ejemplo de las empresas
que deciden ignorar la ley y no tener en
cuenta la reformas a la legislación
laboral
[Música]
después de la publicación de este
artículo
uno de los guardias de seguridad que
habíamos entrevistado me envió un
mensaje diciendo que le habían devuelto
el pasaporte y que le habían pagado
está bien pero es lamentable ver que dos
años después esta empresa sigue
cometiendo los mismos errores
le pertenece a un empresario catari con
mucho dinero en la redacción trabajan
jóvenes periodistas palestinos
pakistaníes o iraníes la mayoría nació
en Qatar de padres que vinieron a
trabajar al país
para
jefa de la sección de reportajes esta
doble identidad los legitima para
escribir sobre su país de acogida
nos concentramos en las noticias locales
para que los lectores entiendan Cómo
funcionan la sociedad catarín y Quienes
son las personas que viven en catarres
no queremos difundir estereotipos o
sobre los cataríes o el estilo de vida
de éticas los trabajadores inmigrantes
hacen parte del tejido social catarín
Ellos son la fuerza detrás de todas las
obras Y de todos los trabajos que se ven
Y a medida que literalmente construyo en
el país para nosotros es importante
llamar la atención sobre sus condiciones
de trabajo sus derechos y todo lo que
les pasa
también esperamos hacer presión sobre el
gobierno y las empresas privadas
varias empresas han demandado a doha
news tras la publicación de los
artículos que denuncian sus prácticas
ilegales
la redacción asegura nunca haber
recibido amenazas de censura por parte
del estado;
esta libertad de expresión es inusual en
las monarquías del Golfo pero rasán
safur sabe que con el menor paso en
falso todo puede derrumbarse en
Qatar Yo diría que la línea roja sería
insultar a la familia real
de todas maneras nunca lo haríamos a
nadie le interesa eso
personalmente creo que esa es la línea
más Roja
de resto procedemos tanteando probamos
los límites y nos adaptamos paso a paso
para cuidar su imagen de apertura en
occidente la familia real de catarsis
forzado por modernizar y liberalizar las
condiciones de vida de los extranjeros
en un suburbio alejado de doha nos
encontramos con las empleadas filipinas
que aprovechan sus primeros días de
vacaciones en tres años
van a una de las ocho Iglesias de doja
aquí no hay campanas ni cruces en el
exterior
[Música]
desde 2008 este país musulmán Ultra
conservador autoriza el culto cristiano
a condición de que la misa se lleve a
cabo fuera de la vista pública
Este es el regalo que Qatar le dio a la
iglesia católica para que los cristianos
puedan reunirse
el país sigue siendo musulmán nosotros
solo somos una minoría
entonces en señal de respeto no ponemos
cruces en el exterior
y lo que normalmente celebramos el
domingo aquí lo hacemos el viernes
porque es el único momento que las
personas tienen libre
a pesar de las dificultades A sus 49
años Rachel espera poder quedarse en
Qatar hasta que sus cinco hijos terminen
sus estudios universitarios
vine a captar por mis hijos porque el
dinero que se gana aquí tiene mucho
valor en mi país
le pido a Dios que tengan buena salud y
que terminen sus estudios
Total
siempre les digo
terminen sus estudios
Hay que luchar luchar de luchar
y si Dios quiere conseguiremos Nuestro
objetivo
[Música]
nos encontramos con farsana en un barrio
Popular de doha
la jefa de empresa hace sus compras en
las tiendas de los pequeños comerciantes
provenientes de India como ella
[Música]
en Qatar los indios constituyen la mayor
comunidad de expatriados
dame esto esto
y esto cuánto es
nos conocemos desde hace 20 años primero
tuvo un local aquí enfrente y ahora
tiene uno más grande al igual que
farsana todos estos comerciantes están
bajo la tutela de un socio catarín
los trabajadores extranjeros de Qatar
saben que no son dueños de su destino el
tiempo de su estadía está sujeto a la
buena voluntad de las autoridades y
todos viven preocupados ante la
posibilidad de ser devueltos a su país
en el barrio en pleno centro de doha
había cientos de locales administrados
por extranjeros
pero con la llegada del mundial de
fútbol la familia real decidió renovarlo
todo
los comerciantes fueron desalojados uno
detrás de otro
hassan es uno de los últimos en no haber
cerrado su negocio
no me han dicho nada sobre mi local No
lo sé No lo sé
del otro lado de la calle recibieron un
aviso de desalojo y los comerciantes
vaciaron los locales
no sé a dónde fue algunos recibieron una
indemnización otros no
programar aquí con los edificios nuevos
los alquileres van a cambiar si suben me
voy a tener que ir
llegada
creo que después del mundial de fútbol
nos van a expulsar a todos me preocupa
cuando uno vive aquí no es ciudadano
solamente tiene un permiso de residencia
y no sabe cuándo le van a pedir que se
vaya es así todos los expatriados
conocen ese sentimiento
al cabo de 20 años la instalación en
casa de sigue siendo precaria
todavía cocina en una estufa portátil
porque prefiere destinar sus ahorros a
su país de origen
invertía en una casa y en una pequeña
oficina en India
para tener un lugar a donde ir si en
algún momento Dios no lo quiera me tengo
que devolver
cuando uno se instala aquí lo primero
que hace es construir una base en el
país de origen
para poder tener un respaldo
y su familia sueñan con volverse
cataríes
pero salvo en Casos excepcionales es
imposible obtener la nacionalidad
incluso para jasem que nació en doha
hace 16 años terminaste tus tareas
ya casi
pero me parecieron difíciles
cuál es tu país
bueno evidentemente indio pero aquí es
normal todo está bien
India no le gusta nada como nació y
creció Aquí está acostumbrado saben es
feliz aquí de verdad
incluso cuando viajamos quieres regresar
pues se ha convertido un poco en mi casa
Porque vivo aquí desde que nací y aquí
todo va bien
Te gustaría quedarte
[Música]
Sí claro me gusta mucho este país
en diez años Me gustaría seguir viviendo
aquí en el mismo lugar quizás tener una
oficina más grande pero más empleados
Quiero que mi empresa crezca
y después me gustaría quedarme en doha
cuando me jubile
crees que será fácil
creo que después de los 60 años es muy
difícil obtener una visa Entonces no lo
sé
en Qatar el permiso de residencia está
ligado al permiso de trabajo
Los jubilados y desempleados deben
abandonar el país en el Paseo marítimo
de doja el futuro de Ibrahim senson 13
El joven no ha encontrado trabajo desde
que renunció a la empresa que no le
pagaba
[Música]
pronto podría ser deportado
ya no soy empleado de una empresa no
tengo alojamiento vivo en la casa de
unos amigos
a veces me dice vamos a trabajar en una
obra Ven y vamos juntos
si no tomo el metro y Busco trabajo
Estoy buscando una solución para todo
esto
[Música]
este país me hacía soñar tenía una
visión una meta
pensaba que al venir aquí iba a poder
ayudar a mi familia a mis padres a mi
madre
porque ella realmente me necesita pero
no he conseguido nada
[Música]
estos rascacielos son muy lindos pero yo
no veo nada bonito aquí cuando veo esos
edificios tan grandes pienso en el
sufrimiento de las personas que los
construyeron
[Música]
Ibrahim espera poder encontrar algún
trabajo durante el Mundial de fútbol
pero teme tener que regresar a Kenia una
vez el Campeonato haya terminado aún más
pobre que a su llegada
cuando se apaguen las luces de los
estadios
Qatar podría abandonar rápidamente las
reformas laborales en doha cientos de
miles de trabajadores corren el riesgo
de caer en el olvido
[Música]